the cast of this movie is
insane um and it's going to make so many
people watch it just because of this
cast so i'm curious for the two of you
um how much did you pay to be in the
movie
almost with my life thank you yeah yeah
a lot
a lot a lot a lot of money yeah right
i'm
being serious for a second i want to say
that you both did a great job
um harry i am curious uh you have to
deliver a very
powerful sermon in the church and uh
what is it like actually preparing for
something like that are you
like can you do that speech still now i
mean were you like saying it like a
hundred times to get yourself ready i'm
just curious what goes on
to do something like that i can't
remember a single word of it
which is what always happens in whenever
you do anything
um same with theater when you do you
know a hundred and hundred times i can't
remember a single word of it
um and do i do it a lot of times before
no i do it enough times that i feel that
it will be there
and then once i feel that it will be
there i kind of leave it alone otherwise
you just get wrapped up in the same
in in sort of you know you get wrapped
up in it and
it won't feel alive it won't feel like
you're doing it for the first time which
is what it has to feel like
so um you learn your lines the best you
can then you just forget about it really
that's that's what i tried to do
right uh did you uh yeah i was gonna
make some more jokes but let's be
serious but
for the two of you guys for both of you
um i would imagine making this was
a fantastic experience when you think
back um for each of you is there like a
day that really sticks out
like some really strong memorable
moments do you know what i really
enjoyed
um the uh the scene where we go
to the words to pray there was something
really kind of strange about that day
we knew that it was a big scene it had
you know a lot going on um and yet there
was a
like a chaos to it which i really sort
of enjoyed and there was a sort of
catching it all the time which again was
a lot of fun
um and it's uh yeah i really enjoyed i
really really enjoyed that day i got you
know i got to work with two brilliant
people so it was a great day
i'm glad you you mentioned that there
was something about that day in the
forest
there was the chaos and there was the
weather there was a certain amount of
wind and rain that was coming in
and you know and getting the blood right
and and uh and getting the car to stop
in a certain way without going over the
ravine
um yeah there was something in the air
that day i think everybody kind of felt
it
rather palpable yeah uh for both of you
i would uh for people that don't really
know about the movie making process and
what it's like to work on a movie set
what do you think would surprise them or
what surprised even you
about working on this one it's waiting
time i you know
you tell friends who know nothing about
filming or anything
it just happens and you're always doing
something you're not you're waiting
around for a long time
waiting for a particular thing to get
set up so that'll be the thing that i
i often tell people like what should you
just do it you just you know keep
rolling until you get it
it's like no no you've got to wait
around for a long time sometimes
that's the the biggest thing i think
it's kind of the same thing with you
know i'm a touring musician and a
performer in that regard
um first and foremost and it's
i would say the it's not the unrelenting
glamour
that has been that is portrayed right in
so many different ways
um a lot of waiting around um a lot of
like where am i gonna go to the bathroom
right now oh i have to wait an hour and
a half don't you can't wait
and just a lot of people running around
and and
um yeah i just i just for me i have a
hard time sitting still and being quiet
so i basically just
find people to talk to and luckily on a
film set there's a lot of people to talk
to there's always somebody sitting there
like oh god he's gonna talk to me
and there you go i just want to be
left alone listen i already got to stop
i'm just going to say again congrats
both of you were great
uh good luck with the rest of the speed
dating uh have a great day
thank you very much thank you